there are three different types of T
tests the one sample T Test the
independent samples T Test and the
paired samples T Test so what are the
hypotheses of the T Test let's start
with the one sample T Test in the one
sample T Test the null hypothesis is the
sample mean is equal to the given
reference value so there's no difference
and the alternative hypothesis is the
sample mean is not equal to the given
reference value what about the
independent samples T Test in the
independent T Test the null hypothesis
is the mean values in both groups are
the same so there is no difference
between the two groups and the
alternative hypothesis is the mean
values in both groups are not equal so
there is a difference between the two
groups and finally the paired samples T
Test in a pair t test the Nile
hypothesis is the mean of the difference
between the pairs is zero and the
alternative hypothesis is the mean of
the difference between the pairs is not
zero I hope you enjoyed the video and
see you next
time